6 24 it's a must-see show here in las
vegas especially if like me you're
always in the mood for some motown a
soul of motown las vegas performing four
nights a week at the west gate so
excited to have you guys in the studio
they look fantastic
i know it is early uh sean thank you for
being here your wonderful husband here
joining us as well brandon and then we
got mo and cj as well you guys kind of
bring it together bring the show for
folks who haven't seen it
what can they expect when they sit down
in their seat i'm guessing they're not
sitting very long
long at all
not at all um well see with our show we
like to call it more of a party
atmosphere okay um you know a lot of
shows they they they do imitations you
know you know they dress up like them
and with our show it's more of a um
our own interpretation of the song so
you so you get the the feel of the song
but
with a kind of a
new hip yeah
a little better yeah and so
from
from jump normally about 30 seconds in
getting everybody up on the teeth
i'm celebrating motown i love it i love
i love motown music i listen to it all
the time and you know it's interesting
what speaks to you the most about motown
music is performing every night
basically over at the west gate what is
it that that attracts you the most to
performing some of the hits the smokey
robinsons the gladys knights the
temptations of four tops
what speaks to you the most
how do you feel about it well
it's it's feel good music so no matter
what mood you're in motown always makes
brings you
out of that place into a happy place you
can't sit in your seat with motown music
you know and and um
everybody can relate to it you know and
so that's what makes motown special to
me it's the motown sound that makes you
feel good it speaks to the soul right
the heart and soul well speaking of
heart and soul i mean we absolutely have
to see some of the performance that i
know you guys are gonna do a little ah
fun for us so should we just get out of
the way and and let them take over do
your thing i think so
almost got it on good day las vegas
i got sunshine
on a cloudy day
when it's cold outside
i've got the month to make
well i
guess you
say
what can make me feel this way
[Music]
[Applause]
is over at the west gate right now go
see them now fantastic show you guys
sound amazing
you're
thank
you
the valley uh three years now running
wonderful show like john said four
nights a week at the west gate guys
thanks for coming in this morning we
really appreciate it for having us